I'm so excited and very grateful to
Great Britain and
that you support us that you hosting
that that you
support ukrainians refugees and thank
you for all missions and all that all
what you make for us thank you so much
for us this is a huge support this is a
part of resistance for me represent
again and be together with a
huge audience this is a part of our
resistance and today we can say that
cultural Ukraine will win and I know how
you support us thank you so much once
again I'm so grateful
you you must though despite your
excitement your obvious excitement at
performing in in Liverpool you must be
somewhat sad that it is not possible yet
for Eurovision to be held where you are
to be held in Ukraine
huge friend of Ukraine and I know that
good times will happen I like good days
will come and we can have the Eurovision
in a brilliant country Ukraine Brave
country
uh you of course we've just been looking
at pictures of you performing and for
the troops out in the front line how was
that for you because presumably there is
there is a little bit of danger involved
in going out to places like that I mean
was it was it did it ever cross your
mind not to go and see your Ukrainian
country men and women on the front line
yes this is was not safety of course but
this is
how we support each other how we stay
shoulder by shoulder on each front
doesn't matter how what the profession
you have you I'm just you know I'm
singer and now I'm like culture Diplomat
for me very important to bring and lift
up our culture lift up our people and
look at the bravest soldiers they are
fighting their protect our country so I
protect the soul I protect them
like a singer and give a hope
what are your hopes Tina as we as we you
know we we are now in the the second
year of this conflict what are your
hopes for your country Ukraine when you
speak to those troops on the front line
I mean do they give you any indication
that they think they are going to do
anything other than be victorious in
this conflict
I think that this is our wish that this
is Win
um and build a new country
uh beautiful with a strong people and
strong motivation to be the best and one
of the best in the world today I think
the heart of the all our Earth between
here in Ukraine
tell me a little bit about Vladimir
zielinski obviously now president but
before he entered politics I understand
that you two knew each other back when
he was he was more of a performer than
he is perhaps now
we're proud of him we're proud of our
leader and this is a very hard decision
for him and
to fight
trust me this is not easy and he give us
will say a mission and understanding
what is Ukraine what is ukrainians and
how Brave we are so he give the first
impulse that gave the people hope
and we how you see we break we're very
proud of him
um well Tina we're gonna we're gonna
have to leave it there but we're all
very much looking forward to your
performance at Eurovision it's only a
few weeks away now uh we will see you in
Liverpool for now though thanks very
much for joining us thank you so much
and see you soon